is there anything that you can say to
people who who have that kind of
ambition who may be working in small
Independent films lower budget films but
really want to to get to the kind of
scale and scope that you're working at
now how did you do it and and and what
can you say to people who are looking to
do that I I asked this question once to
Martin scorsi because uh before I went
to Hollywood and he said to me stay
intact try to do as as the best as you
can do to stay intact meaning protect
your your integrity protect your your
identity protect your identity stay
yourselves try to be yourself and make
no compromise that's what I would say
yeah